يتواصل في السودان خرق الهدنه ويتواصل
معها تبادل المسؤوليه عن خلقها بين طرفي
النزاع وضمن تبادل البيانات اتهم الجيش
السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بمواصله
انتهاك الهدنه بينما تتهم الاخيره الجيش
بمهاجمه قواتها وعلى الارض بددت
الاشتباكات المتقطعه امال السودانيين بوقف
النار فيما ينذر استمرار المعارك بتفاقم
الازمه الانسانيه والصحيه في انحاء البلاد
ووسط تجدد خلق الهدنه اكثر من مره منذ
دخولها حيز التنفيذ ليل الاثنين تسعى لجنه
المتابعه والتنسيق لاعاده الهدوء ووقف
اطلاق النار هذه اللجنه مشاهدينا تعنى
بمراقبه الهدنه وفق ما نص عليه اتفاق جده
وتضم تلك اللجنه قيادات من طرفي النزاع
بالاضافه الى مسؤولينا سعوديين وامريكيين
اما بالنسبه لاليه عملها فلا تفاصيل كثيره
عنها الا ان المسؤولين الامريكيين كانوا
المحو سابقا الى احتمال استعانتها
بالاقمار الصناعيه والى جانب المراقبه عن
بعد لا شك ان تلك الاليه ستدرس ايضا او
تدرس الاتهامات المتبادله التي يتقاذفها
الجانبان عللا وعبر بيانات رسميه للتحقق
من هذه الانتهاكات حول ذلك وللمزيد ينضم
الينا من ام درمان الصحفي مقداد حسن اهلا
بك معنا مقداد اذا خروقات مستمره ولا
معلومات مؤكده حول من يبدا هذه الخروقات
ومن يستمر بها ولكن انقل لنا الصوره لديك
حول ذلك هل ما زالت قائمه الخروقات هل ما
زلتم تسمعون
داويين انفجارات طلق نار طيران جوي ان كان
في ام درمان او المناطق التي فيها
اشتباكات ايضا مثل بحري والخرطوم كذلك
نعم فاطمه بالامس كانت الاشتباكات
القصف الجوي بالاضافه الى المدافع الثقيله
كانت هي سيده المشهد وكانت الاصوات عاليه
جدا ولكن في الساعات الاخيره من الليل بدت
هنالك طلقات متقطعه واشتباكات ومطاردات
داخل احياء مدينه شمال ام درمان تحديدا
مما يعني ان الاشتباكات قد يعني نقصت
حدتها في في ساعات المتاخره من الليل وحتى
الساعات الاولى من الصباح هنالك هدوء كبير
في مدينه ام درمان خصوصا في شمالها
وجنوبها لكن شوهد الطائرات الاستطلاع في
هذا الصباح تحلق في سماء ديرمان وسمعت
ايضا اشتباكات متقطعه في وسط الخرطوم
وبالتالي فان التجدد هذه الاشتباكات
وكذلك ينتظر من الاليه المراقبه ان تفعل
الهدنه بطريقه وانت يلتزم الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع بالهدنه حتى تصل
المساعدات الانسانيه لمدينه ام درمان
والخرطوم وبحري والتي يعني نشهد فيها
انقطاع كبير في اغلب امدادات الغذاء
والدواء وكذلك الخدمات الاساسيه من مياه
وكهرباء مدينه بحري على وجه الخصوص تشهد
انقطاعا للمياه منذ بدء هذه المواجهات
وكذلك احياء كثيره جدا من مدينه ام درمان
تنقطع فيها خدمات المياه والكهرباء ويعاني
المواطنين بصوره واضحه وبالغه جدا خاصه في
المناطق التي تقع في محيط النار او محيط
المناطق الاستراتيجيه كسلاح المهندسين
والسلاح الطبي والهيئه العامه للاذاعه
والتلفزيون وكذلك الجنوبي مدينه ام درمان
حيث معسكرات الدعم السريع
بما يخص القوافل الانسانيه والجانب
الانساني بحسب من تحدثنا اليهم من اللجنه
العليا لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه تحدث عن
انه هنالك
مساعدات غذائيه وصلت الى شمال مدينه ام
درمان حيث
قاعده وادي العسكريه لكن لا وجود لسلاسل
او شبكات امداد لان بحسب هذه اللجنه تقول
ان الطرفين لم يلتزم التزاما واضحا وهناك
التوترات امنيه واضحه تمنع دخول هذه
المساعدات الغذائيه فيما يخص المساعدات
الطبيه كانت اللجنه الهلال الاحمر ووزاره
الصحه ايضا كانت قد تسلمت هذه
المعينات الطبيه ولكن ايضا تواجهها صعوبات
بالغه في ايصالها الى المستشفيات المطلوبه
هنالك حديث عن ان مستشفى النوم في مدينه
ام درمان وكذلك مستشفى بشائر في العاصمه
الخرطوم جنوبي الخرطوم والمستشفى التركي
قد تسلمت بعض من هذه الادويه
والمعينات الطبيه والمستلزمات الطبيه هذا
هو المشهد كاملا بما يخص المساعدات الطبيه
والغذائيه نشاهد يعني مشاكل انسانيه بالغه
وصعوبه وتعقيد كبير في السلاسل وتامين
الكوادر التي تعمل
هذه المعضله والمشاكل الانسانيه التي
يواجهونها المواطنون السودانيون اثر هذه
المعارك والاشتباكات مع ضيفنا التالي شكرا
جزيلا لك من ام درمان الصحفي مقداد حسن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات